this is one of 37 labs in india where
scientists are using a process called
genome sequencing to decode the genetic
information in covet 19 to learn more
about the virus the samples of every
positive case in north and central delhi
are kept in this freezer at nearly minus
80 degrees celsius
scientists show us a device called the
flow cell which collects the samples
it's then inserted into a machine that
reveals their genetic code the director
of india's biggest covert 19 hospital
says they have their best minds
analyzing the results to see how the
virus changes into new variants and
understand how these changes affect its
characteristics
we have the phd scholars we have the
researchers we have the professors
doctors who are full time working rather
they are working more than 12 hour per
day
allen jp hospital's coronavirus ward is
receiving international passengers
who've tested positive for the virus
upon their arrival the government has
imposed tighter restrictions at
international airports including
mandatory covert 19 tests for arrivals
it's also delayed the resumption of
international commercial flights as
other governments go further and ban
flights from countries which have cases
of omicron economists say the new
variant is already having a global
impact uncertainty leads to slowdown in
investment
and investment is what leads to growth
and to employment generation right now
any kind of uncertainty that increases
affects the financial markets as we saw
the stock markets immediately declined
they may recover a little but as long as
the uncertainty remains the financial
markets will get affected and investment
will get affected you know
sociologists say while many are anxious
about another possible wave governments
must keep the poor in mind as they
decide next steps there are different
kind of people
in this country and in this world and i
think the impact of kovid has been felt
and experienced very differently across
different social categories of people
and i think that's something which we
need to underline not because for some
kind of sociological reasons but also
for policy reasons
the first year of the pandemic pushed
230 million indians into poverty